okay and we're back we're back guys
we're gonna it was fast because this
game crashes every five [ __ ] seconds
ok now okay here's a here's it here is
that right here ma'am ma'am I'm out of
breath so I need your car good good good
thank you for cooperating we gotta go to
this stronghold right here okay okay and
let's go let's go let's hope the game
isn't [ __ ] crash all right so do the
one that does crash I think it's because
the second ancient
and so we just got it you know she was
startled probably because you felt the
bullet whizzing past her head and I like
this is how it goes oh sorry sir
I'm just like a burger joint
all right let's do this let's do this
oh [ __ ] tough [ __ ] GPS like same
sculture found
okay I don't know why the [ __ ] GPS told
me go this way but all right yeah we
love my gat okay good good good let's
there's II and I guess it's just tired
poppin check it out you're looking at
the old toy Institute for science and
innovation but the place isn't all
Jacob's Ladder and irrigation [ __ ] in
the center of it all is a bunch of
servers that run the Ronan's where porn
ring those [ __ ] are making serious
Bank off this site God can't take those
bad boys out the Ronin are definitely
gonna be hurt wow porn is so great
Troy's gonna get his okay
oh god get gun gun i yielded I to gut
gut gut and I yet so I guess alright
yeah ok I guess I just saw want to die i
guess uh I'm not really sure you know
like I like when they they dodge cuz
then i get the fire again you know
that's just how i roll what I got to go
upstairs what is this what is this good
oh oh oh [ __ ] where are you [ __ ] you're
so above me or Shawn below me and I'll
[ __ ] now what cigs zooming a bit up
up up what's up here oh nothing I like
that on that was a good shot oh good i
like when they take hostages because
that means there's more for me to shoot
at you know like what is that see them
on the map it's going to crazy
I fire a lot because that means i could
kill more um hello ma'am yeah they see
that in there like firing at me like it
was cool nerds okay gotta get some
servers gotta get some server sound yeah
yeah I love me taking down service yeah
yeah uh uh I gotta take down the service
yeah yeah yeah and there ain't nobody
gonna stop me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I'm just a server killing
sucker good good I just whack them with
my gun um because sometimes I don't like
to shoot my gun i'd just like to whack
with it um I'm a charge and kind of dude
you know I can't okay good good good
okay okay good to hear I hit the head
for the doors do I know I know now I
don't I don't um but I don't really make
the rules here [ __ ]
oh it's by a helicopter it's like this
is earring back and forth yeah oh my god
are you serious ooh why that happened
I just
oh god get I I guess that's it guys
that's how you take a stronghold and I
like
oh god has a good one on the good one
now let me just save cuz this game is
[ __ ] terrible okay that's good now
can I just like jump out of here I know
will probably kill me but I don't really
don't feel like walking out of there if
I get let's just let's just see how this
plays out oh wait these are my guys why
are you in my way Santa not babies under
attack i buy this okay huh
like I didn't know I'd become like a
business magnate but you know like it
who knows how life is gonna turn out you
know like that's what I'm saying yeah